guyancourt ville de 29 mille habitants
et membres de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour le second
tour des élections municipales trois
listes sont en lice françois morton le
maire sortant est arrivé en tête avec 42
% des voix il est suivi de rodolphe
barry candidats ensemble agissons pour
guyancourt se maintient aussi grégory
pas candidat et les oem et tête de liste
nouvel élan à guyancourt
à noter qu'un quatrième candidat s'était
présenté en mars dernier l'écologiste
olivier paréja a choisi de rallier la
liste de françois morton avec sept
autres colistiers principal enjeu à
guyancourt l'ancienne friche thales et
son aménagement cette zone implanté
entre l'avenue léon blum et celle de
leurs apps devrait accueillir d'ici 2030
plus de 1300 logements des commerces des
activités économiques des espaces verts
et des services publics sur plus de 22
hectares le site qui sera baptisé le
quartier des savoirs va accueillir
également la future station de métro
saint quentin est du grand paris express
un super métro reliant orly à versailles
en 30 minutes
avec ce nouveau quartier le nombre de
guyancourt soit devrait passer de 29
mille à 32000 les logements justement
seront d'un deuxième enjeu à guyancourt
la ville compte actuellement près de 48
% des logements sociaux
c'est 18% de plus que la moyenne des
communes voisines est la ville a entamé
depuis quelques années une
reconfiguration de ses quartiers
notamment des transformations dans le
quartier du pont du routard depuis 2006
l'un des plus vieux quartiers de la
ville créée en 1974
dernier point les entreprises la ville
compte à ce jour 2536 firme sur son
territoire presque 1000 de plus qu'en
parmi elles des grosses entreprises
comme sodexo le groupe à ce mode est
spécialisé dans les jeux de société ou
encore le technocentre renault qui
emploie près de 9500 personnes la ville
doit-elle accueillir plus d'entreprises